bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du mois de plus 5 t le tout nouveau
smartphone de one plus en trois minutes
[Musique]
30 minutes tech on lance le compteur
prendre du tech pour parler du wan plus
saintes et le nouveau smartphone de one
piece avec un écran qui occupe plus de
80% de la face avant un écran 6 pouces
full uptick amoled de 18 9e une
résolution de 1080p 2160 pixels à 400
tpv la technologie sun life display qui
lui permet d'adapter automatiquement sa
lumière directement quand il ya de la
lumière fort du soleil on ait la
possibilité d'étalonner son écran selon
quatre modes le mode par défaut le srgb
le mode dci p3 et le mono d'apt hâtif
côté photo vidéo il a un double capteur
photo de 16 et 20 mégapixels à l'arrière
de l'appareil avec une ouverture en 1.7
des performances améliorées en faible
luminosité la technologie étaient les
hôtes pixels qui lui permet de réduire
le bruit à faible luminosité et
d'améliorer la netteté un autofocus
ultra rapide un zoom numérique x 2
toujours en effet bloqué pour flouter
l'arrière-plan
côté vidéo peut filmer en 4k usd à 30
images par seconde avec une
stabilisation eu un sc berne
effectivement de corriger les
tremblements au niveau du smartphone on
peut également filmer en full hd en 1920
par 1080 à 60 images par seconde par
contre si on veut du ralenti faudra
descendre en 720p pour avoir du 120
images par seconde
on peut aussi les détails menace à
l'avant pour trouver une caméra de 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture de 2.0 et
vous pouvez filmer en full hd à 30
images par secondes pouvaient
déverrouiller directement par le capteur
en céramique qui se trouve maintenant au
dos de l'appareil
on l'a utilisé déverrouillage faciale
avec plus de 100 points de
reconnaissance de votre visage côté
design il un beauty monop coque
aluminium anodisé avec des bornes
légèrement arrondi une teinte midnight
black
il mesure 156 points un par 75 par 7,3
mm et il pèse 162 g il a un double
lecteur de carte sim une prise jack
côté performances il a un processeur
qualcomm snapdragon 835 une puce
graphique adreno 540 mais disponible
selon cj dias mans 8 gigas de ram
lp ddr4 x il est bien évidemment du
bluetooth 5.0 côté os on trouve en
oxygène 4,7 sur un android fait point
pour un nougat
il dispose d'une batterie 3300 milliards
erreurs et bénéficie de la recharge
rapide de wons plus le la charge permet
d'avoir une politisation en seulement
une demi heure de charge
a priori sur chartres et plus
manque que le samsung galaxy note 8 on
retrouve dans la boîte le one + 5 t
adaptateur et le câble de recharge
les écouteurs one + bullet v2 lac côté
tarif il est dispo en si j'y viens avec
64 giga de ram à 499 euros et 1 8 gigas
de ram avec 128 go de stockage à 559
euros côté point positif il ya le fait
que seul bloc
la puissance avec le processeur la puce
graphique et les 8 gigas de ram
le design élégant le grand écran amoled
et l'autonomie points négatifs pas de
certification ip67 min p 68 et pas de
ralenti vidéo en full hd si vous avez
envie non plus hein qu'est ce que vous
devez changer est passée à eaubonne +5
des mages dirais non pas forcément
alors même s'il veut plus 5 t est un
excellent produit il est beaucoup trop
proche du 25 mai processeur même puce
graphique même mémoire
il apparaît par une dalle 6 pouces sous
une dalle 5 25 pouces une caméra
légèrement améliorées le moins de plus 5
t est une évolution du vin de +5 sans
être forcément une grande révolution
à qui s'adresse aux jeunes +5 tu es tout
simplement possesseurs de ce qu'il y
avait des anciens modèles de shiwan plus
à tout ce qui vient du note marc et qui
veulent en plus santé d'une excellente
qualité au final est ce que ce soit le
plus forte quand mon produit oui sans
papiers en tous cas c'est un excellent
produit
maintenant j'ai hâte de pouvoir réaliser
un test complet
voilà qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui en
trois minutes sur ce one + 5 t dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez est ce que
c'est un téléphone qui pourrait vous
intéresser ce que vous avez déjà des
téléphones ou all christ est ce que vous
avez le web + 5
qu'est ce que vous pensez de one plus en
règle générale marquée moto sans
commentaire on discute on se trompe
enfin nous on se retrouve très bientôt
pour un prochain format de trois minutes
tech d'ici là portez vous bien
mettez-moi des jolies pouces vous invite
à vous abonner la chaîne parce qu'on a
toujours toujours toujours plus de
contenu pour parler de high tech
soyez sages porter vos gardes je vous
embrasse
[Musique]